[Music]
it's chocolate
[Music]
i'm sorry my dear friend i mean i'm
enjoying this season i do get annoyed
that everybody gets to get out of jail
free card now and like they don't be
sending nobody home [ __ ] what's wrong
with going home first it
so i need banji's hot tape who is vanjie
rooting for on season 14. don't give me
no pageant answer you said hot tape so
hot take automatically my mind goes to
alyssa hunter cause
once they put your toothpaste for
straight
[Music]
you know i know how to point out the
trade but
um
i love willow peel
you know evie's daughter i love
cornbread i mean they're all really good
i love carrie colby her interviews are
funny you've had this incredible career
since appearing on rupaul's drag race it
really has been life-changing is there a
moment that you think back on where
you're like holy i can't believe that
celebrity reached out to me or told me
that they love my work there's one that
stands out of course it's rihanna
because she's my favorite she's always
been my favorite since the beginning of
beginning of beginning the beginning
thank you vangie
vanjie
but
i always gag i'm going i hop on
somebody's live the other day i was on
go to cats live and she was like this
their jeep is banji so i'm always
surprised on how big the show has gotten
how like everyone knows knows us in the
mainstream and like they love the show
and they love us and
it's fierce it's i'm always shocked
i loved watching your true dating story
so much and this is my true what is it
true dating horror story because that's
really what it should be called
nightmare horror story dating live
experience when you got the call saying
do you want to share a true dating story
where you like hell no i don't want to
relive that or were you on board right
away oh i was on board right away i love
to tell stories i have a lot of dating
stories i remember when i got the call i
told them about like five different
stories
and i was like y'all can pick which one
y'all like they are a mess they are
horrible
but i didn't mind i was excited you
should just go home
[ __ ] at that point when he said that to
me it became jose left the building in
mortal kombat was ready to cut i was
ready to beat that ass i don't want to
give too too much away
but what are people going to see and
hear when you tell your true dating
we'll call it horror story it's going to
be a hot fan it's gonna be tables
flipping you know i'm hot-headed kind of
real 200.
and y'all know
they end in the in this day and age it's
not it's a lot it's a lot and i'm real
you know emotional and passionate
[Music]
gonna be a gag the guy was standing
there looking like
like the
hit or solve the movie the ring or
something
everybody making noise
like [ __ ] they saw godzilla
we've seen you throughout your career
you know looking for love yourself and
brooklyn heights uh maybe had a little
kissy kissy on your season of rupaul's
drag race we also saw on rupaul's drag
race vegas review you going on a very
awkward date
as well as a kiss with cameron michaels
may i ask can i be nosy are you single
right now
[Music]
i'm trying to do the beyonce route and
not really tell nobody nothing too much
and have people to do
you know i kind of open book and share a
lot
and i think
you know here you can take that for what
it is
so
vanessa ventu mateo is getting cookies
somewhere
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos